tell us about your role tonight who do
you play I bet the backbone of the
family the glue to the whipple family
and the wife provided mother passed your
question do you have to like a character
as a person to be able to play it or can
you understand maybe why they do certain
things and still want to play that
character well you know in this
situation I I didn't know that I would
respond me personally would respond the
same way my character did and I had to
find a way into it I certainly didn't
judge her I mean it was a really fun
character to play especially playing a
character who's whose life really
changes in that split second and will be
forever different I just I like the
challenge of it right do you think women
across the country can relate to your
character not just in the Midwest but on
both coasts
she's very traditional you know no I I
don't know because I felt like for me I
would have behaved differently so you
know I think it love you won't
understand her maybe but okay alright
well thank you thank you for time
appreciate